REPORT AND THOSE DETAILS.
THAT AND SO MUCH MORE IN
BREAKING NEWS OPENING MONOLOGUE.
>> Sean: WE DWIN WITH MORE FAKE
NEWS FROM CNN, IT IS SPEWING
FROM THE NEWS OF THE CLINTON
NEWS NETWORK PRESIDENT, MARK
ZUCKER.
HE BLASTED FOX NEWS'S PROPAGANDA
MACHINE AND STATEMENT-RUN TV.
GUY THE WAY, FOX NEWS LIKE EVERY
NEWSPAPER IN THE COUNTRY HAVE A
SPORTS PAGE, NEWS PAGE, GOSSIP
PAGE AND EDITORIAL PAGE.
OPINION PROGRAMMING.
EVEN WON'T TO SAY THAT THIS
NETWORK DOES, QUOTE, A
DISSERVICE TO THE COUNTRY.
COMING FROM THE MAN WHOSE
SO-CALLED CABLE NEWS STATION,
CNN, IS NICKNAMED THE BLEEP HOLE
NETWORK BECAUSE THEY HAVE AN
OBSESSION WITH THE WORD YOU
MIGHT REMEMBER THIS.
>> IS THERE A DIFFERENCE IF THE
PRESIDENT SAID, BLEEP HOLE, AND
BLEEP HOUSE.
DO YOU THINK THEY'RE BLEEP
HOLES.
>> DONALD TRUMP HAS TURNED THE
OVAL OFFICE INTO BLEEP HOLE.
>> BUILT THIS COUNTRY 110 YEARS
AGO, THIS IS THE PRESIDENT'S
(BLEEP) COMMENTS.
A FEW MORE.
(BLEEP) COUNTRY.
>> (BLEEP) HOLE.
>> (BLEEP) HOLE COUNTRY.
>> DO YOU HAVE AN EXAMPLE OF THE
(BLEEP) HOLE COUNTRY THAT IS
CAUCASIAN?
>> (BLEEP) HOLE.
>> I WORK FOR (BLEEP) HOLERS.
(BLEEP) (BLEEP) (BLEEP).
>> I'M PROUD TO BE A (BLEEP)
HOLER.
>> (BLEEP) HOLE ON TELEVISION.
SNL JEFF ZUCKER BLEEP HOLE
NETWORK, THEY ALSO HAVE A NEW
OBSESSION, BASICALLY, SOFT CORE
PORNOGRAPHY FROM THE NONSTOP
COVERAGE OF STORMY DANIELS TO
THE CONSTANT SPECULATION ABOUT
AN ALLEGED AFFAIR BETWEEN TRUMP
AND A PORN STAR.
IF YOU LOOK FOR
4/NEVER-ENDING -- 24/7 NEVER
LOOPED AROUND CNN NEWS THEY HAVE
YOU COVERED.
>> THIS COULD BE THE LAST NAIL
IN THE COFFIN.
STORMY DANIELS, IS CAUSING
STORMY WEATHER.
>> STORMY DANIELS CLAIMS
PRESIDENT TRUMP BROKE THE LAW,
HAD HER BULLIED.
>> DOES STORMY CAN YELLS HAVE
THE PRESIDENT'S NUMBER?
SEEMS THAT WAY.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP MAY HAVE MET
HIS MATCH WITH STORMY DANIELS.
>> HOW IS STORMY WEATHERING
THIS.
>> STORMY SPEAKS.
>> WE'RE HEARING FROM STORMY
DANIELS.
>> STORMY IN HER OWN WORDS ISN'T
GOING ANYWHERE.
>> STORMY DANIELS HAS A GOOD
LAWYER AS A PORN STAR, SHE WAS
TELLING THE TRUTH.
>> STORMY DANIELS IS ON A TEAR.
>> QUICK PREVIEW OF STORMY
DANIELS INTERVIEW THIS SUNDAY.
>> STORMY DANIELS.
>> THE REASON HE CAN'T ENGAGE
WITH STORMY DANIELS, SHE'S GOT
HIS NUMBER.
>> Sean: ABOUT AN ALLEGED
AFFAIR, NOT PROVEN, AND OF
COURSE VERY DIFFERENT BILL
CLINTON WITH PAULA JONES,
KATHLEEN BROAD ROCK.
BUT IT DOESN'T WEND STORMY
DANIELS.
THEY'RE GIVING A FORMER PLAYBOY
PLAYMATE KAREN McDOUGAL, GIVING
HER AIR TIME AND TALKING ABOUT
POTENTIALLY, ALLEGED, CONSENSUAL
RELATIONSHIPS.
AND WE'RE GOING TO COMPARE HOW
THEY COVERED, OH, ASSAULT AND
EXPOSING ONE SELF AND EVEN RAPE
WITH BILL CLINTON.
ALL THIS EFFORT, IN THIS CASE,
TO DESTROY DONALD TRUMP.
TAKE A LOOK.
.
>> SO WHEN WAS THE NEXT
COMMUNICATION?
>> I BELIEVE WE TALKED RIGHT
AWAY ON THE PHONE.
AND I THINK WE TALKED FOR ABOUT
A WEEK ON THE PHONE BEFORE HIS
NEXT VISIT TO L.A.
THAT WAS HIS FIRST BIRTHDAY,
JUNE 12 I THINK.
>> WOULD HE CALL YOU?
>> HE WOULD CALL ME.
I WOULD CALL HIM, VICE VERSA.
>> Sean: WELL, CNN'S NEW
OBSESSION.
WE MIGHT HAVE A BRAND NEW NAME
FOR THEIR LEADER, THEIR CHIEF,
THEIR CEO.
JEFF ZUCKER.
THE PORN KING OF CABLE NEWS.
OF COURSE PORN KING JEFF ZUCKER
AND COLLEAGUES AT THE BLEEP HOLE
NETWORK AREN'T ALONE IN THEIR
STORMY OBSESSION.
NBC, ABC, CBS AND OTHERS
FEATURING SATURATED COVERAGE OF
THE STORY.
THE SAME LEVEL OF MEDIA INTEREST
NOT PRESENT IN THE EARLY 1990s
WHEN THEN-PRESIDENT BILL CLINTON
WAS ACCUSED OF HAVING MULTIPLE
EXTRA MARITAL AFFAIRS AND EVEN
INSTANCES OF SEXUAL MISCONDUCT.
WITH GENNIFER FLOWERS, SHE WAS
PROVEN RIGHT BUT I REMEMBER
JAMES CARVILLE, HE WORKED AND
WAS ONE OF THE PEOPLE TALKING
ABOUT IT OR DRAGGING HER THROUGH
A TRAILER PARK ABOUT PAULA
JONES.
REMEMBER HER?
SHE ACCUSED BILL CLINTON OF
LITERALLY PULLING DOWN HIS PANTS
AND EXPOSING HIMSELF.
AND ACCORDING TO THE MEDIA
RESEARCH CENTER, THE FIRST THREE
DAYS OF THAT SCANDAL ABC
PROVIDED A WHOPPING 16 SECONDS
OF COVERAGE.
NBC, CBS, THEY IGNORED IT.
AND NEXT IS THE CASE OF KATHLEEN
WILLY, SHE SAID THAT BILL
CLINTON GROPED, GRABBED,
FONDLED, TOUCHED, KIGSED HER
AGAINST HER WILL INSIDE THE OVAL
OFFICE.
THAT STORY BREAKS, HOW'S YOUR
FAKE NEWS HANDLE IT?
ABC IGNORES IT, NBC, CBS, 34
SECONDS OF COVERAGE.
ACCORDING TO THE MEDIA RESEARCH
CENTER.
CNN DEDICATED 26 SECONDS OF
COVERAGE DURING THEIR EVENING
NEWSCAST.
THEN OF COURSE YOU HAVE THE
SERIOUS ALLEGATION OF RAPE.
JUANITA BRODERICK.
AND I INTERVIEWED JUANITA BROAD
WICK, TOUGH INTERVIEW.
SURFACED IN 1998.
MEDIA RESEARCH CENTER SAYS ABC,
CBS IGNORED THE STORY.
NBC AIRED SEVEN MINUTES OF
COVERAGE.
NOT BEFORE INITIALLY SPIKING ITS
PRETAPED INTERVIEW WITH JUANITA.
THIS PROVES WHAT I'VE BEEN
SAYING ABOUT JUMPISM SINCE 2007
OR 2008, IT'S DEAD AND BURIED IN
THE COUNTRY.
WE'LL HAVE MORE LATER.
JOHN DOWD, THE LEAD PRESIDENT
FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP IN THE WHITE
HOUSE HAS RESIGNED A FEW HOURS
AGO, FOX CONFIRMED THAT VICTORIA
TUNSING WILL BE JOINING THE
PRESIDENT'S LEGAL TEAM.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS BREAKING NEWS
SAYING THAT HE WOULD LIKE TO DO
A SIT-DOWN WITH THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
LET'S DELVE INTO THIS.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> WOULD YOU LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
FRONT OF ROBERT MUELLER?
>> President Trump: THANK YOU.
>> Sean: I'M SURE THE PRESIDENT
WOULD.
AND MY ADVICE TO THE PRESIDENT,
YOU HAVE TO BE VERY CAREFUL.
I'VE BEEN WARNING EVERYBODY
ABOUT ROBERT MUELLER AND HIS
MERRY BAND OF DEMOCRATIC DONORS.
WE KNOW ROBERT MUELLER IS
CONDUCTING A BIASED, PARTISAN,
TOTALLY FLAWED INVESTIGATION.
HE'S GONE WAY BEYOND HIS
MANDATE.
THOSE ORIGINAL PURPOSE, ABOUT
TRUMP-RUSSIA COLLUSION AND WE
HAVEN'T FOUND IT IN OVER A YEAR,
ALMOST A YEAR AND A HALF.
HE WAS APPOINTED, NOT WHAT HE IS
DOING.
CONSTITUTIONAL LAW EXPERT AND
LIBERAL DEMOCRAT PROFESSOR ALLEN
DERSHOWITZ IS POINTING OUBT THE
SPECIAL COUNSELS EXIST TO BRING
ABOUT CHARGES, JUSTIFY THEIR XIS
TENLS.
DOESN'T MATTER IF IT IS AT ALL
CONNECTED TO WHAT THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE INVESTIGATING.
THEY HAVE TO DO ALL OF THIS TO
JUSTIFY THEIR XIS TENLS AT AN
ENORMOUS -- EXISTENCE AT A COST
TO THE AMERICAN TAXPAYERS, ALL
OF YOU, TO THE CULTURE AND
SOCIETY.
THE MUELLER WITCH HUNT HAS BEEN
GOING ON FOR OVER A YEAR.
SO FAR HE'S FOUND NOTHING
REGARDING TRUMP-RUSSIA
COLLUSION.
THE PRESIDENT HAS EVERY REASON
TO BE UPSET.
HERE'S WHY.
MUELLER'S TEAM HAS MORE
DEMOCRATIC DONORS THAN A LIB
BRAT HOLLYWOOD FUNDRAISER.
NOT ONE OF THEM MUELLER'S
PARTISAN WITCH HUNTERS DONATED
TO TRUMP.
EVERY POLITICIAN NOT NAMED
DONALD TRUMP WOULD CRACK UNDER
THIS KIND OF PRESSURE.
XHEEPTLY UNDERSTANDABLE WHEN YOU
APPOINT A TEAM THAT DONATES TO
OBAMA, THE DNC, HILLARY CLINTON
ONE PERSON THAT DONATED TO
TRUMP?
OF COURSE THE PRESIDENT WANTS TO
FIGHT BACK.
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL FROM DAY
ONE, HAS BEEN ABUSIVELY BIASED
AND MANY HAVE QUESTIONABLE
ETHICS, THEY HAVE HORRIFIC
BACKGROUNDS, AND THEY'RE OUT TO
DESTROY HIM.
SAYING I'M NOMENT GUILTY IS HOW
ANY INNOCENT PERSON WOULD ACT.
ROB ROSENSTEIN, HAS STACKED THE
DECK BY APPOINTING HIS BUDDY,
ROBERT MUELLER.
HE HAS CONFLICTS HIMSELF.
JAMES COMEY ADMITTED HE LEAKED
THE MEMOS TO GET THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL APPOINTED.
AND IT HAPPENED.
THIS IS ONE BIG GIANT INSAYS TO
YOUOUS DEEP STATE CABAL TRYING
TO UNSEAT A DULY ELECTED
PRESIDENT.
H.R. McMASTERS HAS RESIGNED AS
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR, AND
HE WILL BE REPLACED BY JOHN
BOLTON.
THIS IS A HUGE IMPROVEMENT.
WE WILL HAVE MORE THAT.
AND TONIGHT, THE HOUSE JUDICIARY
CHAIRMAN BOB GOODLATTE DEMANDING
DOCUMENTS ON THE FIXED CLINTON
E-MAIL INVESTIGATION, WHEN NEVER
WAS AN INVESTIGATION.
ALSO ABOUT SEVERE FISA ABUSE AND
ANDREW McCABE'S FIRING.
HE NOTED IN A PRESS RELEASE,
SOMETHING WE HAVE BEEN REPORTING
ON, CONGRESS HAS REQUESTED 1.2
MILLION D.O.J. DOCUMENTS RELATED
TO THE CLINTON INVESTIGATION.
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL HAS THEM,
WHY WON'T THEY TURN THEM OVER.
"THE HILL" REPORTS THAT THE
CHAIRMAN IS TRYING TO DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT COMEY LIED UNDER
OATH.
SO FAR CONGRESS ONLY RECEIVED OF
THE 1.2 MILLION, 3,000.
WELL THAT SOUNDS LIKE
OBSTRUCTION.
DOESN'T SOUND LIKE THE WHEELS OF
JUSTICE OR EQUAL JUSTICE UNDER
THE LAW.
THE D.O.J. STONEWALLING,
PREVENTING CONGRESS FROM
CONDUCTING THEIR KONSES TUGSAL
JOB OVERSIGHT.
ROD ROSENSTEIN, SUCKING UP TO
PAUL RYAN IN THE FINAL HOURS,
PLEASE DON'T LET CONGRESS HAVE
ACCESS TO THE TRUTH ABOUT FISA
ABUSES.
WE ALL KNOW THE CLINTON E-MAIL
INVESTIGATION WAS A SHAM BUT
COMEY STRUK, McGABE, PROBABLY
LORETTA LYNCH PART OF FIT
PUTTING THE FIX IN.
THE FBI AND DOJ USED UNVERIFIED,
THEY'RE NOT TRUE.
CLINTON POT AND PAID FOR DOSSIER
RUSSIAN LIES TO GET A FISA JUDGE
TO SPY ON CARTER PAIGE AND
ALLOWED THEM TO SPY ON THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
THE MUL BULK OF THE FISA
INVESTIGATION WAS MADE UP OF THE
PHONY CLINTON DOSSIER, FULL OF
RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT LIES AND
PROPAGANDA.
AS ANDREW McCABE TESTIFIED,
WITHOUT NO DOSSIER, IT NEVER
WOULD HAVE EVEN BEEN A FISA
WARRANT APPLICATION.
AS FOR McCABE, HIS COMMENTS
AFTER BEING FIRED, WELL TO PUT
LEGAL JEP SI, McCABE WRITES THE
OIG INVESTIGATION IS FOCUSED ON
INVESTIGATION I CHOSE TO SHARE
WITH THE REPORTER THROUGH MY
PUBLIC AFFAIRS OFFICER IN THE
LEGAL COUNSELOR AS DEPUTY
DIRECTOR I WAS ONE OF ONLY A FEW
PEOPLE WHO HAD THE AUTHORITY TO
DO.
THAT IT WALLS NOT A SECRET, IT
TOOK PLACE OVER SEVERAL DAYS.
OTHERS, INCLUDING THE DIRECTOR,
WERE AWARE OF THE INTERACTION
WITH THE REPORTER.
HE'S NOT ADDRESSING LYING UNDER
OATH.
ACCORDING TO McCABE, COMEY KNEW
HE WAS LEAKING INFORMATION TO
THE MEDIA WHICH IS IN PART WHY
McCABE GOT FIRED, AND LYING YOU
UNDERSTAND OATH CONTRIBUTED.
McCABE IS SAYING NOW, VERY
DIFFERENT FROM WHAT JAMES COMEY
SAID IN MAY OF 2017.
WHO DO YOU BELIEVE, COMBY OR
McCABE?
WE'LL LET YOU DECIDE.
>> DIRECTOR COMEY HAVE YOU EVER
BEEN AN ANONYMOUS SOURCE IN NEWS
REPORTS ABOUT MATTERS RELATING
TO THE TRUMP INVESTIGATION OR
THE CLINTON INVESTIGATION?
>> NEVER.
>> UM, QUESTION TWO, RELATIVELY
RELATED.
HAVE YOU EVER AUTHORIZED SOME
ONE ELSE AT THE FBI TO BE AN
ANONYMOUS SOURCE IN NEWS REPORTS
ABOUT THE TRUMP INVESTIGATION OR
THE CLINTON INVESTIGATION?
>> NO.
>> Sean: YOU GOT TO WONDER IF
STEPH NO LIS AT ABC, CLINTON'S
BFF, THE LIBERALS ON "THE VIEW,"
STEPHEN COLBERT, RACHEL MA
DOUGH, WILL THEY ASK FOR JAMES
COMEY ABOUT THIS?
WE WON'T HOLD OUR BREATH.
JAMES COMEY IS WELCOME ON THIS
SHOW.
WHAT IS BECOMING MORE APPARENT
BY THE DAY IS HOW THE DEEP STATE
IS FIGHTING BACK AS THEY
CONTINUE TO GET EXPOSED.
THEY'RE NOT LIKING WHAT IS
HAPPENING.
WE ARE EXPOSING ON THE SHOW.
PERFECT EXAMPLE, FORMER OBAMA
CIA DIRECTOR JOHN BRENNAN.
HE'S NOW TRYING TO MALIGN
PRESIDENT TRUMP WITH A BRAND NEW
CONSPIRACY THEORY.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> I THINK HE A'S FRAYED OF THE
PRESIDENT OF RUSSIA.
>> WHY?
>> WELL, I THINK ONE CAN
SPECULATE THAT, THE RUSSIANS MAY
HAVE SOMETHING ON HIM PERSONALLY
THAT, THEY COULD ALWAYS ROLL OUT
AND MAKE HIS LIFE MORE
DIFFICULT.
CLEARLY IT IS IMPORTANT FOR US
TO IMPROVE RELATIONS WITH
RUSSIA.
BUT THE FACT THAT HE HAS HAD
THIS FAWNING ATTITUDE TOWARD
MR. PUTIN HAS NOT SAID ANYTHING
NEGATIVE ABOUT HIM, CONTINUES TO
SAY TO ME THAT HE DOES HAVE
SOMETHING TO FEAR.
>> Sean: GREAT, A KNOWN LIAR BUT
THE MEDIA PAR REPORTS BRENNAN'S
TALKING POINTS.
LOOK AT THIS.
>> FORMER CIA DIRECTOR WHO
WORKED FOR PRESIDENTS ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE IS DEEPLY
CONCERNED.
>> IT'S SO CLEAR AT THIS POINT
THAT VLADIMIR PUTIN AND HIS
ASSOCIATES, SOMEBODY HAS
SOMETHING ON DONALD TRUMP.
>> THE BIG QUESTION WE'RE ASKING
TODAY, WHY DOES THIS PRESIDENT
FEEL THE WAY HE DOES ABOUT
VLADIMIR PUTIN?
>> THAT MAY BE SOMETHING THAT
TURNS THE KEY IN THE RUSSIA
PROBE, FIGURING OUT WHY THIS
PRESIDENT IS SO DEFERENTIAL TO
PUTIN AND RUSSIA.
IF THERE IS SOME SORT SOMETHING
THEY HAVE ON HIM.
>> Sean: PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS
BEEN 50 TIMES HARDER ON RUSSIA
THAN OBAMA EVER WAS AND ABOUT TO
TAKE THE LEGS OUT OF VLADIMIR
PUTIN'S ECONOMY AND HE'S NOT
WHISPERING, OH, AFTER THE
ELECTION I WILL HAVE MORE
FLEXIBILITY.
BRENNAN ALSO THREATENING
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
LOOK AT THIS TWEET.
THE FULL EXTENT OF YOUR
BAYTALITY, MORALTER PI TUD
BECOMES KNOWN YOU WILL TAKE YOUR
PRAISE AS A DISGRACED DEMAGOGUE
IN THE HISTORY.
YOU MAY SCAPEGOAT ANDY AK CABE
BUT NOT DESTROY AMERICA.
AMERICA WILL TRIUMPH OVER YOU.
BRENNAN WHO VOTED FOR A DEEP
STATE SWAMP RAT, ALL OF HIS
FRIENDS EXPOSED.
HERE'S A LITTLE HANNITY HISTORY
LESSON ON BRENNAN THAT THE MEDIA
WON'T TELL YOU.
ADMITTED FOR VOTING FOR A
COMMUNIST PARTY CANDIDATE.
HOW DID YOU BECOME THE CIA
DIRECTOR?
YOU HAVE TO WONDER.
MAYBE ROBERT MUELLER SHOULD SEE
IF HE'S COLLUDED WITH THE
RUSSIANS.
THAT'S NOT ALL.
THE NEW YORK POST REPORTED THAT
THE HOUSE INTEL COMMITTEE IS
INVESTIGATING JOHN BRENNAN AND
HIS TIES TO THE CLINTON BOUGHT
AND PAID FOR DOSSIER.
THE SAME COMMITTEE IS LOOKING
INTO WHETHER BRENNAN XHIPTED
PERJURY WHEN HE TESTIFIED UNDER
OATH LIKE HIS BUDDY McCABE WHO
AS HE CLAIMS TO HAVE NO IDEA WHO
PAID FOR THAT DOSSIER.
THE POST ALSO REPORTING THAT
JOHN BRENNAN BRIEFED MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS INCLUDING FORMER
DEMOCRATIC SENATOR HARRY REID
ABOUT THE PHONY DOSSIER.
IF YOU REMEMBER, REED PUT OUT A
STATEMENT AFTER MEETING WITH
BRENNAN, BEFORE THE ELECTION,
AND REFERENCED THE DOSSIER.
BRENNAN TOLD HIM.
BRENNAN IS DIRTY, POLITICAL AND
CORRUPT AS THEY COME.
NOW LASHING OUT BECAUSE WE'RE
ALL FINDING OUT WHO HE REALLY
IS.
WE HAVE MORE BREAKING NEWS TO
TELL YOU ABOUT.
THE HOUSE INTEL COMMITTEE HAS
PUT AN END TO THIS RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION, 14 MONTHS, AND
THEY WILL HAVE A VOTE TO RELEASE
TO THE PUBLIC THE REPUBLICAN
MEMBERS' FINAL REPORT.
THE HOUSE INTEL COMMITTEE
REALIZED A SUMMARY OF THE KEY
HERE ARE THE HIGHLIGHTS.
AFTER 14 MONTHS, INTERVIEWS WITH
ALL OF THESE WITH ITS, THE
COMMITTEE FOUND NO EVIDENCE OF
TRUMP-RUSSIA COLLUSION.
THE LIBERAL MEDIA, THE
DEMOCRATS, LYING TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
JAMES CLAPPER, NUMBER TWO,
FORMER OBAMA DIRECTOR OF
NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE, FAKE NEWS
CNN CONTRIBUTOR, HE PROVIDED
INCONSISTENT TESTIMONY ABOUT HIS
CONTACTS WITH THE MEDIA.
I GUESS COMEY IS GOING TO GET
HIRED NEXT AND THEN BRENNAN.
MAYBE STORMY.
MEMBERS OF THE PARTISAN PRESS
ARE WATCHING, FIRST REPORTED
THIS LAST WEEK.
IT'S CALLED INVESTIGATIVE
JOURNALISM, REAL NEWS.
GUYS MIGHT WANT TO TRY IT SOME
TIME INSTEAD OF SPINNING THESE
CONSPIRACY THEORYS.
THIS WOULDN'T BE THE FIRST TIME
CLAPPER HAS LIED TO CONGRESS.
BACK IN MAY OF 2013, LET'S WATCH
CLAPPER LIE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> DOES THE NSA COLLECT ANY TYPE
OF DAPT A AT ALL ON MILLIONS OR
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS?
>> NO, SIR.
>> IT DOES NOT.
>> NOT WITTINGLY.
THERE ARE CASES WHERE THEY
COULD, INADVERTENTLY, PERHAPS,
COLLECT.
BUT NOT WITTINGLY.
>> Sean: OH, LYING THROUGH HIS
TEETH RIGHT THERE.
THAT SEEMS TO BE THE STANDARD
OPERATING PROCEDURE FOR THE
OBAMA DEEP STATE ACTORS.
POINT THREE, THE COMMITTEE FOUND
HOUSE INTEL COMMITTEE, ZERO
EVIDENCE OF PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
PRECAMPAIGN BUSINESS DEALINGS
RESULTING IN ANY COLLUSION.
POINT FOUR, THEY CONCLUDE NO
EVIDENCE THAT TRUMP ASSOCIATES
WERE INVOLVED WITH WIKILEAKS
PUBLISHING STOLEN DEMOCRATIC
E-MAILS.
ANOTHER LIBERAL MEDIA FANTASY.
WITH ALL OF THE COUNTRIES THAT
HACKED INTO HILLARY'S SERVER WHO
KNOWS WHO GAVE IT TO WIKILEAKS.
ONE OF A DOZEN CHOICES.
HERE'S MY PREDICTION, PRETTY
EASY TO GET IT RIGHT, THE REST
OF THE LIBERAL MEDIA IS NOT
GOING TO REPORT THIS TONIGHT
BECAUSE IT PROVES THEM TO BE
LIARS AND PHONY IN THEIR QUEST
FOR JOURNALISM AND TRUTH.
THIS IS ALL DISINFORMATION
CAMPAIGN.
FINALLY, TONIGHT, I'M GOING
LONG, SARAH CARTER, BRAND NEW
NEWS REPORTING, HEADLINE ROBERT
MUELLER, ANDREW WEISEMAN, THE
FBI AND THE MOB, SARAH DETAILING
MUELLER AND WEISSMANN ARE
INVOLVED IN TWO OF THE BIGGEST
SCANDALS IN FBI HISTORY.
MUELLER WAS ACTING U.S. ATTORNEY
IN BOSTON IN THE '80s ALL HE WAS
INVOLVED IN THE FBI'S CORRUPT
HIGHLY UNETHICAL RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE INFAMOUS MURDERER
MOBSTER WHITEY BULGER.
FOUR MEN WERE FRAMED FOR MURDER,
SENT TO JAIL.
TWO OF THEM DIED IN JAIL.
RESULTED IN OVER $100 MILLION IN
DAMAGES TO TWO THAT LIVED.
MUELLER'S PIT BULL, ANDREW
WEISSMANN, THE ROTTEN APPLE
DOESN'T FALL VERY FAR FROM THE
TREE.
HE'S THE GUY IN A 1990 ORGANIZED
CRIME CASE, HE WAS REPRIMANDED
BY A JUDGE FOR EXCULPATORY
EVIDENCE WITHHELD.
ALSO TOLD YOU ABOUT WEISSMANN'S
HARD CHARGING TACTIC IN THE
ENRON CASE, TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE LOST THEIR JOB, FOUR
EXECUTIVES GO TO JAIL,
OVERTURNED, 9-0 AGAINST HIM.
ALL OF THIS INFORMATION IS
SHOCKING.
THAT'S MUELLER'S TEAM.
GIVEN WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT MUELLER
AND HIS PIT BULL WEISSMANN, IT'S